how should someone who is recovered from
covet handle the calculation between the
uncertainty of lasting natural immunity
versus the risks of a vaccine wait this
was about someone who has recovered from
yeah
if it were me um i would not try to be
first second or third in line for the
vaccine
um i mean it depends on how
forward-facing your work is
um yeah i gotta say i don't understand
why we haven't had this conversation
should people who have had kovac be
getting this at all well that's
so presumably
um and i actually don't remember what's
in that
new england journal medicine paper with
the 40 plus thousand volunteers
none of them
i think that they made sure that they
were looking at naive participants who
had not been exposed who had not tested
positive for covid
so i think the answer to this is at
least so far as i know we have no
idea what the vaccine might do um
if you've if you've already had it um is
it
you know exactly as safe which is to say
hopefully very safe and maybe not
but much less effective because it's
only building on natural immunity you
already have
is it really hardly effective at all
because you've already got all the
efficacy that your immune system is
going to have because you've already
been exposed both of those are
possibilities well
let's put it this way what we do think
we know
is that at least on this time scale very
few people get covered twice
yeah so if that's the case yeah and the
dangers here
exist by virtue of the fact that we
don't know what happens never mind
whether it has a different
i mean not never mind but you know it's
a secondary layer of consideration
whether there's some effect that comes
to people who've had covet because their
immune systems aren't and i even look at
the virus
and look at the vaccine differently
that's a likely thing
yeah but before you ever get there
the good of giving people who've already
had covid this vaccine is pretty small
as long as their immunity from covid
lasts and so
we shouldn't be experimenting on anybody
when
a there's not enough vaccine to go
around and b
we don't have any idea what the hazards
are you know at the very least we've got
a large number of people who've had
covid
and they shouldn't need this so and then
you know this gets right to the question
which is
there is going to be some kind of
draconian
you're not allowed to do these things
travel air travel
or go to a concert or whatever unless
you can establish that you've had this
vaccine
and is that the reason that we're going
to expose people
who have had covid to a vaccine that as
far as we know they don't need and might
never need
in order to come out of lockdown in
order to make sure that everybody has
some card that says they've been
vaccinated this is insane um so we
should
absolutely and you know if we had been
slower on the testing front
we would have tested against different
groups there were a lot of people
who were excluded apparently from this
study
it wasn't that big a study and in order
to be able to see
the effects this was very limited who
was
who it was given to and so there's a lot
we don't know about how this will
interact with other
other parameters and there's really no
excuse for us
seeking to vaccinate everybody
especially a category of people who have
effectively been vaccinated by
the virus itself
[Music]